margarita is on the line hey margarita
how are you
hi david anthony how are you guys doing
oh well great how can we help
so um i'm pretty new to your whole
program
but i have a question about student
loans and property so
a little background my husband and i uh
we've been married for about a year
we're both 23 he works at a consulting
firm
and we both make about uh 130
000 after taxes we have about 80 000
in student loans um and our rent is
about 2 000
a month um as you know arlington is
pretty expensive
but we really want to buy a house so i
guess my question is
should we go about buying a house first
and looking in different areas or should
we tackle those
um student loans now yeah you're 80k in
a whole right now so we're focusing on
the student loans
and i'm doing a math right now so you
have 80 000
student loans is that your only debt
yeah
okay cool so you make 130 000 net you're
spending about
um how much are you spending on rent
right now two thousand two thousand
right so you're spending twenty four
thousand dollars
a year on rent another ten thousand
dollars in expenses so
doing the math you can honestly have
this paid off within about
18 months if you really aggressively go
at it
and so now that's not bad now you're in
your twenties i don't even i don't know
you've been married
well this and december it's gonna be our
one year anniversary
okay yeah yeah and so i that's the route
i'm going and i want to say this
as a young person i didn't purchase my
first house until i was what maybe 32
days
32 and and i had the capabilities
financial capabilities to do it at about
28
but i said i wanted to do it right and
when i walked into my house
it was in a peaceful way and i was not
wasting
any money in my 20s renting because i
wasn't
ready to purchase a home
margarita when i first got married the
first property that we rented
which is where you're living right now
we rented way too expensive
arlington is expensive but you
rented too expensive a place for a
newlywed couple
okay yeah you got a nice place yeah
two thousand dollars i mean you really
do and so
you if i were you i would move uh down
in property so that i'm paying less for
my patients
and i would be debt-free in 18 to 24
months living on a beans and rice rice
and beans budget
where your broke friends are making fun
of you
because if you try to keep up with the
joneses in dc
you're going to be broke your whole life
true
because the joneses in dc are nuts
so you just re i mean they're nuts it's
a whole i mean
it's l.a l.a and dc
the biggest put on the dog world there
is
so you just got to say we are 23 years
old we're going to take two years
and get out of debt and build an
emergency fund and we're gonna live
in a less than ideal
uh place for less than two thousand
dollars
and we're going to pile up a big pile of
cash and then when we buy a house at 26
we're gonna put down a huge down payment
and we're gonna be in a whole different
place
than those yolo friends of ours who are
making fun of us
yeah because you know yolo is the new
way of saying
thank god it's friday oh god it's monday
spend everything we make have no money
you make good money
you're in an expensive area but this is
very
very doable it is very unwise to buy a
home
where you have to buy an extra bedroom
for sallie mae
it's a really good idea to give her her
eviction notice while you're still a
renter
you're debt-free you have an emergency
fund you move in with a good strong down
payment and then you can quote anthony
when i walked into the house there was a
sense of peace
sense of peace but if you move into a
house with an eighty thousand dollar
student loan
and you're 24 years old and you're 100
you've been married a year
a year and a half at that point two
years and
you're broke but you make a hundred
thirty thousand dollars a year
what are you freaking congress yeah you
spend everything you make
and just to look like you're not broke
yeah and you're
you know i'll tell you what will happen
sally may move in the bedroom
and three weeks later the heat and arrow
go out on this new place and you'll find
out the difference between renting
and owning then is you get to do the
repairs
you know what dave i get a lot of
pushback uh from people who say you know
what i'm wasting money by renting and
i'm
wasting money by paying off my student
loans waste your money we're paying off
student loans yes because they're like
well hey
why is warren's going to pay them it
goes back to the government like why pay
them if they're going to be forgiven and
if they're not required to be paid right
now why pay them
because they're not going to be forgiven
and you're going to be saddled with them
the rest of your life and they're the
major impediment between you and
building wealth there you go dave
that's the bottom line i i didn't tell
you the problem with believing a fantasy
is it'll screw up your finances yes sir
and when you believe dc is going to
solve your problem you have a huge
problem if
you believe politics politicians of
either party are going to solve your
problem
then you have just condoned your
condemned yourself to a life of
mediocrity right
because i've been sitting around waiting
for people to send me money out of dc
for 60 years
i still hadn't got any me neither all
i've ever seen is they take money
yeah they don't give money they're a
tick on my butt yeah they're a parasite
so unbelievable then on the flip side
dave um a lot of people think
especially i'm seeing this younger
generation wanting to jump into
purchasing a home
but they're not in a position and ready
to purchase a home so someone becomes a
curse instead of a blessing there you go
dave i was just about to say that
i stole it i stole your lies gracious
david
let me say that your dream becomes a
nightmare
here's the thing my generation i mean
we've been married
uh 38 years yeah was the first
generation maybe my parents a little bit
of that generation
was the first generation to buy a home
within five years of marriage wow
up until the 19th and up until about
1960
newlyweds did not consider buying a home
and no one in the culture told them it
was wise to buy a home
they all said you just got married
doofus shut up and save money
wow wow it's gonna you know it was it
was normally you were 30 years old
and you'd been married five or ten years
before you could put together enough
cash to buy a home
but enter fha loans with three percent
down yes
enter va loans with zero percent down
and enter this idea that home ownership
is always grand and it's not sometimes
it's 50 grand
yes sure is and it doesn't it it'll
break your butt
when you buy a house and you're broke
it's a problem